One of the things about hunter that's really toxic hating is that his sort of
self destructive path becomes romantic when you read it and you get involved in
his work and you kind of mimic it,
you know,
it's,
uh,
that's the greatest fallacy I think.
I think what he was trying to say with self destruction was that this was an
incredible threat to our American democracy.
Now,
I don't mean that,
I mean,
I mean his snow romanticism teaching his,
well,
I mean the romantic aspect of it was that his work was fantastic.
I mean,
window was till it wasn't,
it was fantastic till it was,
it wasn't,
I mean,
he understood what it was in the filial it was,
but he lived in with,
he spent much more time within the consequences of that bingeing than he did
within the success of the bingeing.
And that,
I think he knew that his letters,
it's really beautiful and heartbreaking.
And in his writing too,
I mean,
I think that's what's been missed about him is there's no romanticism and self
destruction right towards the end.
He definitely lost his productivity and Yon Warner talked about that in the
Alex,
give me document three.
He just,
sticky fingers was a great,
the document I,
the new book on the new book on Yon Winter has great moments of Thompson the 70s
just being kinda lost.
Yeah.
You know,
I think,
I think we got to remember that we have an incredible times in American history.
We have times that are going to burn brightly and it's up to each rider to
decide how they'd like to burn next to it.
And if you're going to burn brightly,
they may not have other times.
And that's I think an American thing where you can wager that bright flame,
which means you may have nothing left afterwards,
but Thompson knew that he may have to live in that kind of afterlife at Juan.
Juan Thompson writes about it so beautifully straight as I taught myself.
There's some,
some footage of him when he was writing for,
I forget what newspaper somewhat.
Was it somewhere in the Pacific northwest.
What,
what was your writing for?
Who is the author of playing off the rail?
D Google.
Uh,
playing off the rail.
There's a guy who was a journalist,
but year,
do you think it was David Mccumber?
Yes.
David McCumber.
David McCumber employed hunter for awhile when David was,
um,
I forget what publication he was working for,
but there's some footage of them community communicated together and you know,
just trying to get hunter husband San Francisco was in San Francisco and hunters
out of his fucking mind.
I mean,
it was younger.
he wasn't even that old,
but he was just wrecked.
He just couldn't communicate.
He couldn't talk.
And uh,
you know,
he made be,
he makes a beast.
You escape the pain of articulation.
You escape the pain of saying this is what's wrong.
And American Society for him to say the way he did one of his great essays from
1964.
So by going to Hemingway's,
um,
Ketchum,
Idaho,
I'm grave in Hemingway's house and it's gorgeous because it talks about
Hemingway was a good writer,
one of the best writers when he was writing about an a period.
He understood the 1940s,
1930s,
when there was a firmness to the reality that he could articulate.
One of the writers goals is give a pattern to chaos,
is to give an articulation of cass.
But what happens in the 1960s when the chaos is multiplying repeatedly,
somebody like Hemingway becomes a literal relic.
Like his narrative no longer fits into the present that he's in.
And Thompson saw Hemingway's decline and he wrote about Hemingway's,
um,
a suicide bomber.
His narrative doesn't fit Hemingway's idea of what America was and what a man
should be fit perfectly with what I think the twenties to the forties when we
experienced.
But I think in the early 1960s with our social upheaval of civil rights,
of,
um,
you know,
political upheaval,
Hemingway,
it was confusing to him.
It didn't,
it didn't fit anymore.
Like his way of operating no longer articulated the present.
And so Hemingway's last act was to take away his ability to say anything at all.
That was his only,
the last thing anyone ever said was to say,
I'm not gonna say anything anymore.
Was the suicide that Hemingway committed.
And Thompson wrote about that cordially.
Yeah.
When,
when he was young,
when he wanted to kill him himself,
it was almost unsurprising,
you know,
when,
when I read that he had died,
I remember going,
Oh man,
well I guess,
yeah.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
it's like you knew that he was deteriorating rapidly.
You knew that he had really bad hips.
He had had hip replacement surgery,
um,
the Ralph stuff and leg.
Yeah.
Ralph Steadman had drawn this very crazy image of him with the artificial hip
and yeah,
it looked like pain,
you know?
I mean,
but I think that it stopped my place to even deal with that because one
Thompson's book writes about that moment,
or one time Thompson was in the house and that's,
that's,
that's his and one rights shoe to flee about the stakes of it,
how painful it was to the people that loved him chorus,
everything about it.
Um,
and how that,
even if that's a logical outcome at that's not,
no,
it needed it.
So it's interesting,
I would say read stories.
I tell myself that moment is so honestly and brilliantly written by one.
No,
I'm sure both Bamo oh I was getting at is that at the time of his death,
you know,
he was in to sort of,
uh,
he was deteriorating so badly.
He was wearing diapers.
His,
his entire cause of his alcoholism has ability to control.
A spotter was gone.
And so one gave this wonderful speech at George Mason when he came out and he's
like,
how do you write honestly about your father?
And he asked the question of like,
should I include this detail?
And he was like,
if my father was alive,
I couldn't include that.
But that's why I chose innocence to write my book when my father was dead
because I think my father would want me to write honestly,
but also not want me to include that if he was still alive.
And so he included that detail and he talked about that,
how the struggle to include that detail,
which I think brilliantly articulate what you're saying,
which is the deterioration in the sadness of it.
And I mean,
we have finite amounts of energy or effort.
We really do.
We have to take care of ourselves.
And if we don't,
we will pay that price,
um,
at point,
we're going to pay it anyway.
So we're all headed to the same place that we want to or not,
you know?
And so I think hundreds of really terrifying and beautiful example of one wager
of chips that were made for that 1960 and 1970s and I think the best way to
honor that as to,
you know,
apply the brilliance that he forged and carved to the situation we have right
now with corruption.
Donald Trump.